is natto fermented soybeans, a food that is good to add to my diet.
I was diagnosed with estrogen driven breast cancer four years ago.
So normally if it was just soy beans, if you were eating tofu, I would say no.
But natto is a Japanese traditional Japanese dish that is fermented soybeans.
You can make your own with soybeans. You'd want to get organic soybeans.
Because most soybeans on the market are GMO soybeans, which is another issue.
But get organic soybeans and you put them in the oven.
There's a procedure to do it. I was going to make them one time, but I didn't do it.
But that is how you would make your own natto.
Natto fermented soybeans is used in traditional, like I said, in Japanese dishes.
As a little side dish, they'll have like a large table spoon of them that they'll have at every dinner.
Positive fermented soybeans have been shown to dislodge estrogens from estrogen receptors.
So using fermented soybeans or in a food product, like natto, works differently than using an aromatase inhibitor product, like dim.
So dim and other natural aromatase inhibitors help your body clear bad estrogen.
So it helps you get rid of bad estrogens. It decreases your total estrogen load, which is great for people with an estrogen positive cancer, or even a PR positive or her too positive cancer.
But you're not going to get rid of all your estrogens and it will not dislodge bad estrogens that have already attached to estrogen receptors on the cell membrane.
Because that's really what the problem is with estrogen driven cancers, hormone driven cancers, attached to the hormone receptors on the cell membranes, which are actually apoptotic receptors.
So they block apoptosis. That's the problem with with estrogens and estrogen driven cancer.
While even drug aromatase inhibitor will even do a better job of getting rid of all your estrogens.
That's why a lot of people don't like taking it because you'll have no estrogens left in your body, even the good estrogen, and it can make you feel not well.
It does not dislodge bad estrogens from the estrogen receptors, only the fermented soybeans will do that.
So to answer your question is our fermented soybeans in the form of a food like NATO, a good food source for someone who has estrogen driven cancer, absolutely yes.
The negative is it's definitely an acquired taste. So if you've never tasted it, you might not like it.
So it isn't acquired taste that you can work up to, but if you like it, you should be taking it.
You should be eating it every day. You should be very good for it.